this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday September 26th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the war in Ukraine began experts have
been talking about the threat of cyber
warfare but the massive devastating
cyber strikes that they've been warning
about so far haven't come to pass
now a growing body of evidence suggests
Russia's Military Intelligence Agency
the gru may be working with pro-russian
hackers and online activists to
coordinate their strikes that
information comes from the cyber
security research for a mandiant a part
of Google and it's sending a worrying
signal about the possible volume and
damage of hacks to come
here to discuss the findings is our
cyber security reporter Robert McMillan
hi Bob thanks for joining us hi Zoe
great to be here so what's the evidence
of the connection between Russia and
these hacking groups or hacktivists
well the cyber security firm mandian has
taken a look at a number of break-ins
and they've spent a lot of time tracking
the official
government-sponsored hacking over years
they've tracked a lot of their activity
and what they've noticed increasingly is
that when these break-ins happen within
like 24 hours of the break-in suddenly
the hacktivist groups have the data from
these same networks and they're leaking
it they're saying we've broken in and
we're leaking this data so what made it
is saying like this looks like
coordination to us it looks like the gru
hacking team is breaking in stealing a
bunch of data and somehow just handing
it off to these activists who then dump
it to further cause trouble for the
entities they're hacking what are the
hacking groups that are involved and
have we seen attacks from them before so
there are literally two dozen Russian
hacking groups and the activism in
Russia go back 15 years but really what
we're talking about are a number of
groups that were formed right around the
beginning of the war and the two most
interesting to me of them are one called
killnet and one called hacknet now
hacknet is the group that the mandian
team is saying might be working with
Russian intelligence but kilneg
is this kind of crazy Beast kill that
apparently started as a business like
Wii U can rent this kilnet network and
and will attack any entity you want like
just give us money and then when the war
broke out they started doing more and
more patriotic stuff and kill that has
members who have actually appeared with
their faces obscured and their voices
changed on Russian television they're
kind of celebrities there so Mandy it
says like we think maybe killnet and
hacknet are working together you know
definitely hacknet is is working in
concert with the Russian intelligence
agencies killnet we're not so sure but
now
killnet is the one that in the last few
months has been targeting U.S entities
and so you've got uh this kind of murky
world where there's potential Russian
intelligence connections and now you
have companies like Lockheed Martin and
this lesser known company called gorilla
circuits which have been been targeted
by killnet what have Lockheed Martin and
Guerrilla circuits said about those
attacks well lucky Martin didn't comment
on the attack directly but they said
they're often targeted by hackers now
gorilla circuit says hey we were hacked
back in the fall
and we notified everybody who needed to
be notified after the hack I don't think
the consequences of either of these was
particularly devastating it's really and
this is the game of the hacktivist right
they try to sort of have some kind of
effect and then they amplify that and
that's a big PR win it seems like
there's a Grassroots support for the
Russian war and NATO allies are paying
the price for that
Russia has denied that it's involved in
hacking but how concerned should the
West be about the kind of coordination
described by these researchers the
concern here is that these hacktivist
groups now that they've established
these Brands they could do something
really damaging and Russia could get a
pass for that Russia could say could
have plausible deniability say and they
could say hey we didn't we didn't do
this you know we didn't take out this
power plant or turn off the lights in
Baltimore or you know it wasn't us it
was just hacktivists right when in fact
the Russian government may be calling
the shots here when the war in Ukraine
started there was a lot of talk that
this was going to be kind of the first
cyber War given this strategy does it
appear that that is not going to be the
case this still is going to be kind of a
cloak and dagger uh when it comes to
cyber attacks hey cyber war is Cloak and
Dagger I mean that's what we're seeing
like these hacktivist groups launching
attacks for like eight months now and um
there have been these ongoing wiper
attacks there have been satellite
networks of affected I mean this is
cyber War we're seeing what it looks
like it's not like everyone expected it
to be it's much more like 19 uh 14
trench warfare you know that is
um you know the Blitzkrieg or something
like that but it's
my I guess when this is over there's
going to be a lot of analysis and we're
going to find out that there was a lot
more going on than we realized all right
that's our reporter Robert McMillan
thanks for joining us Bob my pleasure
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]